We Begin this hour with a look at this
Summer's movie season the Super Mario
Brothers movie is the highest grossing
film of the year so far with more than
1.3 billion at the box office globally
but some of this Summer's Blockbusters
could top that they include the new
Mission Impossible film starring Tom
Cruise of course Oppenheimer Barbie and
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
here's a clip of Harrison Ford reprising
his role as Indiana Jones in the movie
[Music]
well they didn't get out the doors get
in the pool
I'm not sure what the dial of Destiny is
it doesn't sound particularly terrifying
but uh Fandango's managing editor Eric
Davis is joining us now to talk a little
bit about what to watch and what not to
watch yes right um great to see you as
usual I'm not going to start with that
though I gotta start with the Barbie
movie because I said to Christina
yesterday did this movie already come
out because I feel like it's been
advertised forever I mean the marketing
now it comes out July 21st first of all
and it's the barber Heimer weekend this
is what they're calling it because it's
you can't talk about Barbie without
Oppenheimer but yeah Barbie the
marketing is just everywhere and it's
brilliant you know why this marketing is
so brilliant it's because so much of it
immerses you in the world of Barbie you
can Airbnb the dream house you can put a
Snapchat lens on you can put yourself on
a Barbie poster and say which Barbie or
Ken am I
stop it I did not I am the Ken who eats
too much pizza I already know that about
myself uh Barbie who needs a nap
but it's you know this is just bright it
pops it's fun it's got a cast it's the
viral movie of the year and so I think I
think a lot of people to go see it but
is it for kids no it's not necessarily
for young young kids there are 43 other
Barbie movies that you could show you're
really young I thought you were going to
say there are 43 year old kids but you
know they're building this is like a
comic Adventure it is directed by Greta
Gerwig who also co-wrote it so it's
going to have some deeper themes as well
um but yeah I think the young young kids
may not get it as much but they'll like
how colorful it looks okay
all right now are you supposed to do
Oppenheimer and then Barbie or Barbie
and then Oppenheimer because my brother
is in it he's gonna do this seven hours
he's going but he can't decide on the
order yeah they call it barberheimer I
would do Oppenheimer or is it open Arby
oh yeah it could be either one okay but
I would do Oppenheimer because it's
probably the drama it's it's it's a long
drama it's based on J Robert Oppenheimer
Who is credited with creating the atomic
bomb it is a Christopher Nolan movie I
would see that first and then the
lighter movie second so you're walking
out with a smile on I say Barbie is the
movie you see with your friends
Oppenheimer is the movie you see on the
biggest screen you can well Oppenheimer
is not your sort of frothy Summer movie
were you gonna say that it's not typical
summerfair no and it's not typical from
Christopher Nolan necessarily either
he's known for his like big sci-fi genre
kind of head spinny kind of movies and
this is more of a of a drama and a Bible
but you actually say that the movie of
The Summer potentially is the new
mission Possible movie brought to you by
Paramount Global I do I'm disappointing
well whatever it's Tom Cruise it's the
seventh Mission Impossible movie though
right yeah but why does it have the
potential to be the movie of The Summer
well I mean look this is a franchise
that gets better with each installment
and I think it is the movie of the
summer because it very much is that sort
of quintessential action Masterpiece
that you want to watch right smack in
the middle of summer uh things to know
about this one it is a part one of a
part two so dead reckoning part there'll
be another comes out next summer
as we know how to it's like the Top Gun
of 2023. I think so you know and I think
this film's gonna do even better because
of top gun Maverick last year and you
know this is Tom Cruise driving a
motorbike off a cliff he's really doing
these things putting his life on the
line I think audiences appreciate that
about him and I think that's why they
show up to see his movie so what about
another sequel Indiana Jones that we
just showed there I I mean I'm reading
that it's the best of the series well
it's Indiana Jones punching Nazis for a
couple of hours no it's America's
birthday like that's what I want it goes
this is very America you know I'm
literally taking my family to see this
later this afternoon and I I thought it
was delightful it's great to see Indiana
Jones at retirement age but
counterbalanced with Phoebe Waller
Bridge who plays his goddaughter who's
just wheeling and dealing and scheming
the whole movie the two of them are just
really great and is there something
worth taking the kids to see back to the
kids yeah I can't see Barbie what should
we go well there is a Haunted Mansion
movie that's based on the classic ride
from Disney World and Disneyland not
it's not a connected to the Eddie Murphy
movie of 2003 but it is very much
inspired by the ride you see in the
Parks got a great cast a little spooky
little funny a little exciting I think
it's going to kind of switch up change
up Summer a little bit at the end of
July all right Eric Davis trying to get
us some movies thank you so much